All right, enough theory,
I want to see some command line action.
Not so fast, you might say.
Don't we have to install Gradle first?
Not at all.
Gradle's first trick is that it
knows how to install itself.
All it needs is a shell script, and
a tiny jar that knows just enough
to download and install Gradle.
I have in this directory,
a copy of the Gradle wrapper.
Gradle wrapper consists
of just a shell script,
we've got one for a Mac and
Linux and we've got one for
Windows, and then inside the Gradle
directory you have a tiny jar.
The way the Gradle wrapper works is
you call it with a Gradle command,
it'll check to see if
Gradle is installed.
If it is it'll just
pass along a command,
if it isn't the Gradle wrapper will go
ahead and download Gradle for you first.
Let's go ahead and run the Gradle
Shell Script and see what happens.
We didn't already have Gradle
installed so now it's downloading it.
You see a lot of dots.
Even more dots.
All right.
There we go.
Gradle's been downloaded.
Welcome to Gradle 2.3.
Hm, it looks like Gradle
decided we need some help.
This option to see a list of
all available tasks looks good.
Let's try running this.
So let's try running the tasks
command using the Gradle wrapper.
Whoa, that's a whole lot of tasks
that Gradle already knows about.
And as we scan through
all of these tasks,
looks like there's a task
that's calling out to us.
Let's give this one a try.
Now let's use the Gradle
wrapper to run the hello task.
Along with some diagnostic output,
we get a nice greeting.
How sweet.
Gradle has to do a significant
amount of work to start up.
Mainly because it's required to spin up
an instance of the Java virtual machine.
This startup time can be mitigated by
using the Gradle Demon, a demon is just
a process that hangs around in
the background of your operating system,
doing something useful.
When Gradle's instructed to use a demon,
a demon process has started, and
continuously runs in the background,
keeping the JBM instance alive, so
that subsequent Gradle runs
can use the same instance.
By default, Android Studio always uses
this as Gradle demon, when running
Gradle from the command line however
you'll have to explicitly enable it.
Simply put you should always
use a demon when possible.
By using the demon you can take
advantage of huge performance benefits
that are planned to get even better
in future versions of Gradle.